[Music]
turning off El open Line
[Applause]
parade there's a cover up that's about
to happen here this is a situation room
I read Kennedy shot in head the
assassination of a president and then a
scramble by the US government to hide
information from its people so much
information was hid from the American
public like how many how many how many
shots re fire
three the question of who shot JFK and
why has riveted America since that
horrifying day 60 years ago but over
time it's become clear that the FBI and
CIA kept information hidden not just
from the public but from the Commission
in charge of investigating the
assassination this has fueled an
understandable doubt in the official
account including by the way lynen B
Johnson the president who took JFK's
Place Congress even came out in the 80s
saying that this was probably a
conspiracy and the public ran wild with
this they came up with hundreds of
suspects of who could have been involved
in the
assassination theories like this Thrive
When government authorities aren't
transparent with their
people so let me show you how this
happened let me explain the official
story and why that story has been hit
with a wave of Doubt over the decades
and explain that unlike a lot of
conspiracy theories doubting the
official story here isn't as crazy as
you might
[Music]
think this was a turning point in
American
history people all of a sudden decide
I'm not sure they're telling us the
truth JFK is this really symbolic
character who lived during a very very
important time in American history and
the story really dives into the context
of what it was like to be an America in
the 60s I'm really excited to dive in
and show you all of the stuff I need to
thank the sponsor of today's video
sponsors allow us to do these super deep
Dives that take months to make with lots
of different people so thank you better
help for sponsoring the video I'm A True
Believer in therapy better help makes
therapy more accessible to people using
technology it is a platform where you
sign up you fill out information about
yourself about what you're struggling
with about what you want to achieve and
then it matches you with somebody in
their Network it's this giant network of
tens of thousands of licensed therapists
who then you can be communicating with
one of those therapists in as little as
48 hours you can communicate with them
on the phone which is what I do I do
phone therapy you can do it over video
call or you can do it over text if the
therapist they match you with isn't a
good fit you can easily be matched with
a new one to try someone else out it
makes therapy accessible affordable and
in my mind D stigmatizes this thing that
we all probably need and don't know it
at least that's how I feel if you do
want to sign up or try it out you can
get a discount there's a link in my
description it is betterhelp.com Johny
Harris when you click the link it helps
support the channel but it also gets you
in on a 10% discount for your first
month of better help so you can try it
out at a discount see if it works for
you and you can cancel anytime if not
thank you better help for sponsoring
today's video Let's dive back into to
this fascinating story of what happened
to
[Music]
JFK people loved John Kennedy he was
this good-looking guy who was always
hanging out with his beautiful family
and he just seemed to instill a sense of
confidence in people Kennedy rode this
positive perception up the ranks of
American politics to become the 35th
President this was in the early 60s when
America was in a giant time of
transition well this is a revolution of
course that is sweeping our country now
the US was the global superpower and was
locked in a cold war with another Empire
a world away so JFK walks into the
presidency to find his military and
intelligence leaders causing a lot of
trouble around the world they had become
very comfortable with dangerous Secrets
they were funding Wars they were
overthrowing governments in far away
countries they were assassinating
leaders that threatened American
interests and they were doing most of
this totally in secret by the way if you
want to know more about those SE asan
anigan go watch the video where we map
all the US coups anyway JFK walks in and
sees this as too much he wants to reign
in the spy and military leaders from
what he sees as an abuse of American
power he ended up firing and demoting a
bunch of these leaders a lot of these
Intel and Military guys who were
plotting and executing covert operations
around the world and he continued to
pursue like his ideal of world peace he
chose diplomacy over violence when
nuclear armed missiles were found in
Cuba he slowed down the momentum towards
a fullcap presence in Vietnam and he
shut down several of these covert
operations that were being planned by
the leaders around him this caused Great
tension between JFK and America's
military and spy leadership all of this
context is important when we look back
on that day in November
1963 Friday morning 11:37 the
president's jet lands at the Dallas
[Applause]
Airport
President Kennedy and the vice president
Lindon B Johnson arrived to Dallas for a
speech that the president was to give he
got in this open top limousine with his
wife Jackie and the Texas governor John
Connelly along with his wife
Nelly they rode through these streets
downtown Dallas lined with cheering
Spectators and then gunshots rang
out Kennedy apparently shot in head
blood was on his head the shots hit the
president in the neck and head also
wounding Governor
[Music]
Connelly the president was rushed to the
hospital where he was pronounced
[Music]
dead and very often you'll find a zipper
hidden in the uh
arm
and good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
you'll excuse the fact that I'm out of
breath but President Kennedy and
Governor John Colony have been cut down
by assassins bullets in Downtown Dallas
the president has rushed to Parkland
[Music]
Hospital within hours of the
assassination the prime suspect became
this 24-year-old former Marine a
self-declared communist who had
renounced his American citizenship and
moved to the Soviet Union where he then
fell disenchanted with life in Russia
and moved back to the US eventually
ending up on the sixth story of this
building in Dallas where he worked and
where he was on that morning in November
where he aimed a rifle and shot the
president his name was Lee Harvey Oswald
and after these shots rang out he fled
while on the Run he shot and killed a
Dallas police officer before hiding in a
movie theater and then eventually being
arrested at around 2:15 p.m. that day I
didn't shoot anybody know there was to
be a trial and Oswald planned to plead
not guilty claiming the whole thing was
actually a setup
py which is like an old timey term for
like the Fall Guy the the one who was
set up that same day the vice president
Lyndon B Johnson was rushed back to the
presidential plane and sworn in as the
new president of the United States
before taking off and heading back to
Washington at the same time the FBI the
top investigatory body in our country
descends onto Dallas and very quickly
the director of the FBI Jay Edgar Hoover
who's a big part of the story he comes
to a con conclusion as to what happened
this is before any investigation had
really gone forth and Hoover decides
that Oswald absolutely was the one who
did it he was a communist sympathizer he
was a frustrated Misfit and crucially he
acted alone there was no one else here's
a phone call between ho and the new
president LBJ there's no question but
that he is the man now the fingerprints
and things that we have I like some
legal representation these police
officers have not allowed me to to have
any but luckily we have a justice system
and we would find what the facts
actually say Oswald was going to stand
trial where the evidence could be
thoroughly examined where the country
could see for themselves who actually
shot their president and get closure on
this horrifying event where whoever did
it could actually be brought to
justice but that never
happened 2 days after the assassination
while Oswald was being transferred from
Police Headquarters to the county jail a
nightclub owner named Jack Ruby jumped
out in front of the crowd of police
police officers and news reporters and
shot
Oswalt he was quickly rushed to the
hospital where he died soon after the
same hospital where President Kennedy
had died just 48 hours earlier Lee oswal
has been shot I think he got what he
deserved if he's the one that did it it
is difficult to say how long it will
take for the full realization of what
happened to really sink in with oswal
dead there could be no trial no real
sense of justice this left the
government investigators the f mostly
with the opportunity to really own The
Narrative of what happened the very next
day the deputy attorney general sends a
memo to the White House stressing that
the public must be satisfied with this
explanation that Oswald acted alone he
didn't have co-conspirators that were
still at large this had to be the story
and I'll explain why in a sec this memo
also included some wisdom and kind of a
foreshadow of what was going to happen
over the next several decades where the
memo urges the White House to to release
as much information as possible to the
public so as to avoid public speculation
just remember that advice release the
information to avoid public speculation
it's kind of the most important part of
the story we have these recently
released phone recordings between the
FBI director Jed G Hoover and the new
president LBJ and we see in this phone
call that the FBI actually didn't want a
thorough investigation I think it it
would be very very bad to have a rash of
Investigation it'd be a three- ring
circuit
well the only way we can stop them is
probably to point point a high level one
to evaluate your report that I can
select out of the government tell the
House and Senate not to go ahead with an
investigation yes LBJ creates this group
called the Warren Commission and you can
see in these phone calls he was asking
the FBI director who should be on the
commission what do you think about
Alan uh I think he would be a good man
wait did you catch that Alan doues he
was the former director of the CIA he's
one of the guys that JFK fired after he
tried to overthrow the Cuban government
and now he's about to be appointed to
the committee investigating Kennedy's
assassination this did nothing to
instill trust in the commission the new
president appointed a commission of
seven prominent Americans to investigate
the whole Affair the special commission
will have before it all evidence
uncovered by the Federal Bureau of
Investigation and all information
available any agents of the federal
government the warrant commission was
given just 10 months to investigate this
situation using the evidence that was
mostly provided to them by the FBI they
produced this report which essentially
confirms the conclusion that Jay Edgar
Hoover the director of the FBI had come
to in the hours and days following the
assassination that on November 22nd the
shots fired that killed the president
and wounded the governor were fired by
one guy Lee Harvey Oswald the report
stresses that he acted alone they say it
very definitively he nor the person who
killed him two days Days Later Jack Ruby
were a part of any conspiracy domestic
or foreign all of the shots came solely
from the sixth floor of this building
and crucially there were only three
shots fired three bullets how many how
many how many shots were part three any
part of me no all three at the presid
all three at the presid and we have
[Music]
them the report says that the first
bullet likely missed the car complet
completely but that the second one did
something very
interesting it first hit the president
in the back and then exited his chest it
then entered through the governor's back
went through his rib and then exited
through his chest but it wasn't done yet
it then entered his wrist shattering the
wrist bone and then exited the wrist and
went partially into the governor's
leg whoa okay it's quite the journey for
one bullet oh and the bullet in question
which just apparently made Seven wounds
supposedly looked like this which some
ballistic experts have said looks a
little too pristine for a bullet that
allegedly just went through two human
bodies and then of course the third
bullet according to the Warren
Commission was the one that delivered
the Fatal head shot to the president
this was the explanation that the Warren
Commission came up with to explain all
of the wounds that were found on the
victims all of this damage had to be
done with just three bullets and why
just three bullets again ask Jay Edgar
Hoover right after the assassination uh
we uh on that floor we found the three
empty shells that had been fired they
only found three shells up on that sixth
floor so if all of this damage was done
with more than three bullets that would
mean that there had to be more than one
shooter a conspiracy but there couldn't
be a conspiracy Hoover had adopted this
line of thinking right after the
assassination this assumption that it
was just one guy and that line of
thinking endured into the wor commission
a commission that Hoover him himself
helped the president
assemble in the end the commission used
a lot of cherry-picked evidence provided
to them by the FBI that supported their
already drawn conclusions and in the
process they turned any Focus away from
exploring all the possibilities
including the possibility of a
conspiracy the report focuses almost
entirely on one guy Lee Harvey Oswald
and his three bullets who killed John F
Kennedy the commission answers
unequivocally Lee Harvey oswal was oswal
a member of a conspiracy commission
answers he acted alone they ignored
witnesses that contradicted their
stories they ignored or modified the
signed reports from surgeons and doctors
who worked with President Kennedy
immediately after he arrived to the
hospital that said that the wounds in
the president's like neck chest area
looked like they came in from the front
meaning not from this building that was
behind the president in other words the
FBI and the Warren Commission ignored
the advice from that memo that
admonished the government to release all
of the facts in my mind this was the
biggest mistake and the root of all the
conspiracy theories that exist today the
question I had in all of this is why why
not do a proper investigation that
explores the possibility that this was
done by a group of conspirators instead
of just one guy for me the answer to
this question has a lot to do with the
greatest fears that the American
government and people were facing in the
early
[Music]
1960s first we have to remember that
1960s America was right in the heart of
the Cold War a time of constant
vigilance of fear of nuclear Apocalypse
of extreme tension between these two
superpowers if this assassination was
seen as an attempt to topple the
government or even worse if it had been
organized by the Soviet Union or its
fellow Communist Regime in Cuba that
would create a sense of pain Panic among
the American public it would be a very
different situation than a 24-year-old
communist sympathizer acting alone a
believed conspiracy would also create
pressure from the American public to
strike back which could lead to an
escalation with another nuclear armed
Nation Oh and the CIA also had an
incentive to keep an investigation from
being too widespread at the time they
were secretly conducting all of these
operations to assassinate Cuba's leader
Fidel Castro this was a big deal and it
was a big secret at the time any deep
investigation into possible conspiracy
with Cuba might reveal that the CIA is
trying to assassinate Fidel Castro which
would not be good for the CIA so one way
to read all of this the memos the rushed
conclusion the emphasis on Oswald acting
alone the need for there to only be
three bullets you can see this as a
bunch of government officials scrambling
to keep the American public calm to make
sure that pandemonium doesn't break out
all while reducing the possibility of
geopolitical escalation with the Soviet
Union you can see this in some of these
phone calls where the new president is
deeply worried about keeping the
American people United around a
simplified Narrative of what happened
he's worried that if alternative
theories get out it could threaten our
entire system so their tactic for doing
this was to hijack The Narrative to
suppress and influence the investigation
and make it very simple Oswald did it
that's it here's the problem though
eventually people will do the math and
realize that the government has been
keeping the full picture from them and
that's exactly what happens
next so the warrant commission files its
Report with the official story of what
happened but soon after they do so
members of the Warren Commission
themselves come out and say like they
don't actually believe the story that
the Warren Commission just put out
especially when it comes to the key
assertion that one bullet was
responsible for causing seven wounds I
could not convince myself that the same
bullet stuck was you mean that you
yourself weren't convinced about the
single bullet theory no I was governor
Connelly the one who was sitting in
front of JFK and the one who was
supposedly shot by that one single
bullet he disagreed with the story I
understand there's some question in the
minds of the experts about whether or
not we could both have been hit with the
same bullet I just don't happen to
believe it even the new president LBJ
wasn't totally convinced I mean he was
kind of secretive about it but he
eventually did come out and tell a
reporter from the Atlantic that he
thought that this was a conspiracy that
it was Cuba retaliating against the US
for all of these CIA attempts to
assassinate their leader this was not
good for the Warren Commission and their
story then 12 years after the
assassination this full uncut version of
a strip of film that shows the
assassination of JFK it finally airs on
national TV it's the film shot by the
Dallas dress manufacturer Abraham uh
zuda and it's the execution of President
Kennedy this was the first time that
Americans could see solid Visual
Evidence of this event but why hadn't it
been released earlier to some this film
contradicted the official account from
the Warren Commission and it sparked
this new demand for real answers from a
government that kept behaving like it
was hiding something all of this is
coinciding with a time in American
history where americ an are losing faith
in the federal government you just see
this massive like nose dive all of the
cia's covert operations are starting to
come to light the country is mired in
this endless war in Vietnam the
president's people were just found
spying on their political opponents in a
hotel in DC like the government has not
earned our trust at this point so people
are like it wouldn't be a far stretch
that the government was also behind the
assassination of JFK this was furthered
by the suspicious assassination of
Martin Luther King J J Dr Martin Luther
King the Apostle of nonviolence in the
civil rights movement has been shot to
death in Memphis Tennessee this was all
too much and the people wanted answers
so in a Shining Moment of redemption of
our democracy Congress responded by
forming a committee that reopened the
investigations into these two
assassinations JFK and MLK this
committee did a real investigation they
actually were Earnest about this and
they confirmed what a lot of Americans
were already feeling which is that the
Warren commission's investigation didn't
sufficiently look into the possibilities
of a conspiracy they say it Point Blank
they were way too fixated on their
assumptions that it had to be this lone
gunman that did it and that their
conclusions were way too definitive and
then they specifically call out the FBI
and the CIA for withholding information
from the investigation one FBI agent
even testified that he was ordered by
his superiors to destroy evidence in
this case a letter that Oswalt had
written to the FBI he handed to me and
he said oswalt's dead now there can be
no trial
here get rid of this why was the FBI
asking its agents to destroy evidence
the committee concluded that it was a
quote high probability that it was two
gunmen that fired at JFK and that it was
probably a conspiracy that's what it
says but they sto short of trying to
determine who that other gunmen was or
who had organized the conspiracy and
then they once again make the
recommendation that all of the
information on this topic be made public
isn't it time for the American people to
at least know what happen happened at
12:30 p.m. in Dallas Texas on November
22nd
1963 quick caveat the committee's
conclusion that the assassination was
probably a conspiracy relied heavily on
one piece of evidence which was the
sound recording from that day where you
can hear gunshots and you hear more than
three and it kind of inferred that there
were like multiple Shooters this
evidence was later challenged and kind
of debunked by the FBI but also a
different research facility that
basically said this sound recording
wasn't even gunshots it wasn't even
recorded during the time of the
assassination but to me the whole
conspiracy thing was not actually the
most important part of this committee's
report the most important part was that
they confirmed that the Warren
Commission had been cherry-picking
evidence and hiding stuff from the
American people after the Congressional
committee confirmed to the American
people that the FBI and the CIA had been
hiding evidence the conspiracy theories
rose up once again culminating in this
movie in the early '90s that that paints
an alternative picture of what could
have happened here a shadowy government
conspiracy to kill the president or at
least a conspiracy to cover up the real
story oswal Ruby Cuba the mafia keeps on
guessing like some kind of polyan
prevents him from asking the most
important question why why was Kennedy
killed who benefited who has the power
to cover it up the film was largely
conjecture kind of based on some
elements of truth and some might argue
that it was irresponsibly misleading to
like show the American public like hey
the government killed the president but
hey in a world where the government
isn't being clear and forthright to the
American people this film felt like a
response maybe the government was hiding
the truth maybe the government did do it
or maybe they're just covering something
up we don't know because they haven't
released information this was a popular
movie and people latched on to the
theories presented in this film the
notion that there were more than one set
of Shooters the way that it's presented
physically in this movie is highly
convincing public pressure got so
intense that Congress finally decided to
do what they should have done in the'
60s which is force all of these agencies
to release all of the information so in
1992 Congress passes this law that would
lay the foundation for releasing all of
the documents related to the
assassination by October 2017 that was
the deadline they assembled a committee
and gave them several years to go
through all of the documents and
reexamine the official account and
prepare these documents for release to
the public we actually talked to the
chairman of that committee I was
nominated by President Clinton to uh
chair the assassination records review
board in the process of going over all
of this documentation this review board
found some more inconsistencies and
discrepancies and instances of potential
cover up like the autopsy there's an
entire video I could make about just the
autopsy and the missing brain and all of
this but the Crux of it is that what the
doctors and surgeons saw moments after
the president was shot they recorded and
they like wrote down but then what the
official autopsy record actually looked
like when it was released was something
very different the way the wounds were
described where the wounds were what the
brain looked like all of this stuff had
been changed or modified the photos
themselves had potentially been changed
and then the brain itself like literally
went missing it's like unaccounted for
so anyway that's an entire rabbit hole
that you can go down if you want to
releasing all these records also
revealed that the CIA and FBI had been
keeping tabs on Oswald's whereabouts
which maybe makes sense because he was
like a Soviet sympathizer but like why
didn't we know that before we learned
that the Secret Service had destroyed
documents the original motorcade route
sheets that they had the surveillance
tapes from that day they had destroyed
them now we found those documents in the
hands of another agency so ultimately
there was no harm judge tunheim said
that yes they got a lot of documents but
a lot of stuff was still missing like
there was one guy at the CIA who took
control of the investigation a couple
weeks after the assassination and all of
his records are just unaccounted for now
did he destroy them all maybe I don't
know there's no real record of that so
you still have that uh previously
destroyed issue in total they finally
released 5 million documents by 2017
basically everything except for a few
thousand documents that this CIA still
refuses to
release why guys come on you can find
this whole Trove of JFK documents on the
National Archives website we'll put a
link in the description okay but here's
the craziest part of all of this even
after 5 million documents were released
to the American public to a public that
was like hungry for like conspiracy
still there is no solid Smoking Gun
evidence in any of this that points to a
conspiracy that points to anyone other
than Le Harvey Oswald as the person who
assassinated the president by himself
acting on his own now the evidence may
exist somewhere but it's been destroyed
or whatever the point is the government
could have released these 5 million
documents in the' 60s like they could
have done this back when people wanted
it back when they should have and it
wouldn't have changed their official
story and it would have satiated an
American public that was skeptical of
their government at this point though I
think it's too late the feeling that the
government was hiding something has now
sunk deep into the American psyche we
all kind of are like the JFK
assassination yes something was up there
I'm not really sure they're ever going
to regain our trust on this one because
of how much hiding of information there
was throughout all of these decades so
on the internet all around from people
who are actually pretty credible you
have alternative explanations that
abound maybe it was LBJ who planned it
so that he could be president or what I
believe is perhaps the most feasible
Theory which is that some Rogue faction
in the CIA wanted to take out JFK
because JFK was against what the C was
up to he was shutting down their covert
operations and then there's of course
the idea that Cuba did it I mean that's
what LBJ the president after JFK thought
like he was like it was probably Cuba
because we've been trying to assassinate
their leader the point is that because
of the information vacuum left by the
CIA and the FBI holding back evidence
from the American people people started
to look at the evidence they did have
and grasp at any evidence they could
find for conspiracy they started
connecting the dots of the witness who
met mysterious or suspicious deaths many
theorists will fixate on this mysterious
man holding an umbrella in this video on
a sunny day maybe giving the signal to a
second shooter it's all very tantalizing
and some of it is actually very valid as
like leads for further investigation but
despite a lot of really fishy stuff I
have not seen any solid evidence that
proves an alternative story to the one
that was told to us back in the 60s that
Lee Harvey Oswald was the guy who did it
and he acted alone I think it's very
plausible that there could be some
conspiracy I think we will never know
because we simply don't have the
evidence one thing I do know for certain
though is that the moment this
investigation turned into an effort to
stifle information and influence the
facts towards one conclusion it laid the
foundation for the public to turn this
into a cesspool of speculation again I
keep going back to that feeling of being
lied to by your government it's very
potent it sticks with you it creates
fertile ground for conspiracy theories
of all kinds to sprout because when you
feel like you're being lied to by your
own democracy by your own leaders no
matter the reason or justification it
makes you feel like you're on your own
like no one's got your back and that you
are the one who needs to find the real
truth and to me it's that space that the
most enduring conspiracy theories find
their
footing have you ever committed any act
of violence in your
life
[Music]
no